Let's go next to our call or from the two,
six, seven area code.
Who's calling today from two, six, seven.
Oh, hi David.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Who's this?
Uh, my name is, uh, Tony Holland.
All right.
Tell me what's going on.
Phil Philly.
All right, very good.
Um, well I wanted to talk about, uh, reparations
and how I just don't pretty much agree or
I'm not really hearing any realistic.
Uh, I don't know.
I just don't agree with the way that the conversation
is taking place, even from, uh, you know,
my, uh, my fellow black people.
Um, so here's a stance really quick, real
rundown.
It's all about slavery, Jim Crow, segregation,
red lining.
Uh, we all know those kinds of things that
we're very well versed in.
How I, what I feel is that, um, uh, white
America has a standard response for that,
which is, uh, we are going, uh, maintain,
uh, the white supremacist system that is in
place by saying that all of those people are
dead and we cannot be held responsible.
And I just don't feel that as a community
we have formed a proper response to that.
Uh, so for me, I look at it economically,
black people owned 2% of businesses in the
United States of America, meaning that, uh,
almost a hundred percent of us have to leave
our community to have access to a single opportunity
in this country.
A defining our largest issue.
Uh, the root of our issue is in fact labor
dependent.
Uh, the, the, you know, we have about six
and a half million black men, over 2 million
black women with felony convictions.
And the statistics bear out that there is
a one 10th of a percent of a chance at ever
being gainfully employed again if you are
black with a felony conviction.
Right.
So my whole, my whole thing is, one, I don't
support cash payments whatsoever because there
is no reason.
I just do not see a successful path.
If you were to give a bunch of people money
who have no financial savvy about themselves,
then it's just going to be a waste of money.
So for that I agree with, but I support a
comprehensive reparations package that, uh,
that, you know, similar to what Maryanne Williamson
says, I advocate elite $250 billion paid in
$25 billion yearly increments all for the
purposes of, uh, of establishing and growing
black owned businesses and labor dependence
by 50% in a 10 year period.
Yeah.
So listen, basically, I mean it sounds like
you and I are on a pretty similar page.
So I, this actually came up in my conversation
with Sam Harris about a month ago where, uh,
yeah, basically I think that a focus on reparations
in the democratic primary may be counterproductive
to ultimately getting someone to unseat Trump
as a merely practical matter.
That being said, I am very open to the way,
uh, to, to doing reparations.
In a way that is not just throwing cash at
people because that will help some people
to some degree, but it's not going to change
really what we're trying to change at its
core.
So what, what the idea that I like and I am
open to different ways of doing it in terms
of the numbers, is to spend the money in ways
where we're going to boost minority homeownership.
We're going to boost minority entrepreneurship,
we're going to fund education and to start
trying to level out what are the remaining
inequalities of horrible historical realities
in the United States.
So it sounds like you and I are sort of on
similar pages.
Um, yeah.
I mean, yeah, except one point.
Um, I honestly take offense to you saying
that, um, you feel that, uh, basically we'll
lose and submit the election to Donald Trump
if we actually, for once in this country,
try and represent, represent black people
at the point of their most pressing needs.
Well, it's not a question of taking a, I mean,
it's not a question of taking offense.
You could, you could argue that I'm wrong
about it or that I'm
well, well let, let me finish my point.
Yeah.
Um, I just feel like what is being presented
is people aren't really thinking outside the
box for me.
I don't see an issue with the democratic party,
uh, uh, potentially, uh, losing if they just
centered their message around appealing to
the race.
Let me make sure, hold on.
Let me make sure I understand what you're
saying.
I want to make sure I understand what you're
When you say you don't see an issue, are you
saying you don't think Democrats will lose
or you don't care if they lose by focusing?
I just want to make sure I'm understanding
what you're saying.
Do not.
Okay.
What I am saying is I do not think that that
is the reality.
I think that that is the expression of a fear
of the people who haven't really thought about
it beyond a typical talking.
You're right.
And I think here's the important thing to
keep in mind when I say I see it as electorally
risky.
The conversation you and I are having and
the way you and I would go about this I don't
think is the risky conversation, which is
to deal with things like home ownership and
education entrepreneurship.
The problem is that whenever it comes up,
the conversation becomes one of how do you
decide who we give cash to and how much do
we give them?
And you and I both agree that [inaudible]
the wrong conversation and I don't see them
having a conversation that's different than
that one.
That being said, if the conversation they
have is the one you're having, I'm all for
it.
Well, well there's, I think we need to reorient
a discussion and get away from the concept
of cash payments in general.
I think that is the single biggest thing that
holds us back.
I think the second biggest thing is the assumption
that we cannot run on reparations.
And when, uh, one of the, one of the things
that I keep in mind is actually shopping a
reparations package to uh, actually racist
and, and people that are connected to a hate
group such as the KKK.
And what I would say to them was, do you want
less black people working and your place of
employment?
Do you want less black children, you know,
going to school with your white children.
Let me, let me finish before you, before you
say this and do you, uh, over here respond
and do you want less black people living in
your neighborhood?
Well, if you support a comprehensive reparations
package, what we will do is what it will do
is allow for the black community to be self
sufficient and they're going to most likely
stay in Bay area when 100% of them don't have
to leave for opportunities.
All right, let me think more about that part.
I have not given that part thought.
I appreciate the call.
I do want to get to a couple more people,
but I, you've, you've very well explained
your position and I appreciate it.
Thank you David.
I really appreciate your time.
You have to do a fantastic show.
Uh, I came across you a few months ago, maybe
about three months ago, and I don't agree
with everything you say, but I, it's just
everything about your presentation, the way
you speak, the way you present your ideas
appeals to me.
I have listened to the young Turks for five
years, never became a contributor.
I became a contributor of yours within the
first week.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
All right, very good.
Good to hear from Tony from Philly.
Hope to hear from you again.